so have you guys heard about Kanye West
coming out and saying that he wants to
run for president in 2020 yes
it's insane yeah so he made announcement
saying that he wanted to run for
president
um Elon Musk has come out in full
support of him on Twitter so did his
wife Kim Kardashian and as a joke
Tiffany Haddish came out and said that
she will also be running for president
in 2020 and Dave Chappelle is gonna be
running with her I mean what a good show
you know what's scary is I mean if Trump
can win [ __ ] Kanye can win apparently
he hasn't done anything leading up to
this announcement to get him actually
like on the polls so iconic and it is no
idea what it entails it's just I think
Kanye also has a history of mental
illness and I don't think you can be
Americans are like good good artists I
mean we thought that about Trump done
then here we are huh that's for sure I
couldn't no I Mara I was the one with or
saying there's no wait yeah you're on
record saying there's not a chance not a
chance
and then we had Chael Sonnen Anka said
he's gonna win that was like no and
here's why I went through the whole read
the litany of reasons I was wrong
I mean that's it
it's funny how when you live in
Hollywood you think that sometimes you
start to think maybe this is [ __ ]
reality and Hollywood's biggest problem
was telling you this is that they are
putting out movies and TV shows that
nobody's watching and now you add kovin
to it and they don't know how to get
bonded insured and what's happening is
YouTube and original content people who
are doing their own thing are sort of
killing the old Hollywood model so that
Hollywood then nominates for people who
won Oscars and nobody knows who they are
and nobody even goes to see those movies
nobody went saw a moonlight well no one
watch the Oscars either
there's the Oscars no so you have these
people are talking and then you know
it's like even CNN CNN is what people
watch
times when they're in the airport going
from place to place but CNN's ratings
are super low I'm tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]